so next game against central
1900 from Germany
yes the way I play today everyone is dangerous here
so
yes we have reached an Isolani position here
as the first G3
looks similar to pocket
boy well well first of all
make normal development here so now the question
swap, I'll do that, yes,
I actually thought it would
make bishop B2,
yes, pregnant G4, is that an idea
and maybe knight e5c here, yes, you
probably have to go
back here now,
or or bishop F4, yes, well, that would also be
possible,
but it works  a bit strange
somehow in the position
well did
n't stop him from
playing
then F6 maybe
something like that what's next on G5
oh god I'll do it now because I
actually thought I thought
the knight would have moved away I know
it wouldn't have been quite good
I can hit on two and
then G5 yes yes well
I think he has to
at least try H3 or something like that to
bring a bit of confusion into the position
otherwise I'll just take it away
or bishop F3 maybe
I mean so I can make moves  Also just
go to 6, still
no field
so yes then I take it out
and now what happens if I
take it here, let's
just play it simple
if Queen F4 is then simply mated on H2
I thought so
chutney
sometimes light food in between